PROFESSOR: OK, well, we've been
looking at streams, this
signal processing way of putting
systems together.
And remember, the key idea is
that we decouple the apparent
order of events in our programs
from the actual order
of events in the computer.
And that means that we can start
dealing with very long
streams and only having
to generate
the elements on demand.
That sort of on-demand
computation is built into the
stream's data structure.
So if we have a very long
stream, we only
compute what we need.
The things only get computed
when we actually ask for them.
Well, what are examples?
Are they actually
asking for them?
For instance, we might ask for
the n-th element of a stream.
Here's a procedure that
computes the n-th
element of a stream.
An integer n, the n-th element
of some stream s, and we just
recursively walk down
the stream.
And the end of 0, we
compute the head.
Otherwise, it's the n-th the
minus 1 element of the tail of
the stream.
Those two are just like for
Lisp, but the difference is
those elements aren't going to
get computed until we walk
down, taking successive n-ths.
So that's one way
that the stream
elements might get forced.
And another way, here's
a little procedure
that prints a stream.
We say print a stream, so
to print a stream s.
Well, what do we do?
We print the head of the stream,
and that will cause
the head to be computed.
And then we recursively print
stream the tail of the stream.
And if we're already done,
maybe we have to return
something about the
message done.
OK, and then so if you make a
stream, you could say here's
the stream, this very
long stream.
And then you say print the
stream, and the elements of
the stream will get computed
successively as that print
calls them.
They won't get all computed
initially.
So in this way, we can deal with
some very long streams.
Well, how long can
a stream be?
Well, it can be infinitely
long.
Let's look at an example
here on the computer.
I could walk up to this
computer, and I could say--
how about we'll define the
stream of integers starting
with some number N, the stream
of positive integers starting
with some number n.
And that's cons-stream
of n onto the
integers from one more.
So there are the integers.
Then I could say let's
get all the integers.
define the stream of integers
to be the integers
starting with 1.
And now if I say something like
what's the what's the
20th integer.
So it's 21 because we
start counting at 0.
Or I can do more complicated
things.
Let me to define a little
predicate here.
How about define no-seven.
It's going to test an
integer, and it's
going to say it's not.
I take the remainder of
x by 7, I don't get 0.
And then I could say define the
integers with no sevens to
be, take all the integers and
filter them to have no sevens.
So now I've got the stream of
all the integers that are not
divisible by seven.
So if I say what's the 100th
integer and the list not
divisible by seven, I get 117.
Or if I'd like to say well,
gee, what are all of them?
So I could say print stream
all these integers with no
seven, it goes off printing.
You may have to wait a very
long time to see them all.
Well, you can start asking, gee,
is it really true that
this data structure with
the integers is
really all the integers?
And let me draw a picture of
that program I just wrote.
Here's the definition of the
integers again that I just
typed in, Right it's a cons of
the first integer under the
integer starting with the
rest. Now, we can make a
picture of that and see
what it looks like.
Conceptually, what I have is
a box that's the integer
starting with n.
It takes in some number
n, and it's going to
return a stream of--
this infinite stream of all
integers starting with n.
And what do I do?
Well, this is an integers
from box.
What's it got in it?
Well, it takes in this n,
and it increments it.
And then it puts the result
into recursively another
integer's from box.
It takes the result of that and
the original n and puts
those together with a cons
and forms a stream.
So that's a picture of
that program I wrote.
Let's see.
These kind of diagrams we
first saw drawn by Peter
Henderson, the same guy who
did the Escher language.
We call them Henderson diagrams.
And the convention
here is that you put these
things together.
And the solid lines are things
coming out are streams, and
dotted lines are initial
values going in.
So this one has the shape of--
it takes in some integer,
some initial value,
and outputs a stream.
Again, you can ask.
Is that data structure integers
really all the integers?
Or is it is something that's
cleverly arranged so that
whenever you look for an integer
you find it there?
That's sort of a philosophical
question, right?
If something is there whenever
you look, is it
really there or not?
It's sort of the same sense
in which the money in your
savings account is
in the bank.
Well, let me do another
example.
Gee, we started the course
with an algorithm from
Alexandria, which was Heron of
Alexandria's algorithm for
computing the square root.
Let's take a look at another
Alexandrian algorithm.
This one is Eratosthenes method
for computing all of
the primes.
It is called the Sieve
of Eratosthenes.
And what you do is you start
out, and you list all the
integers, say, starting
with 2.
And then you take the first
integer, and you say, oh,
that's prime.
And then you go look at the
rest, and you cross out all
the things divisible by 2.
So I cross out this
and this and this.
This takes a long time because
I have to do it
for all of the integers.
So I go through the entire list
of integers, crossing the
ones divisible by 2.
And now when I finish with all
of the integers, I go back and
look and say what
am I left with?
Well, the first thing that
starts there is 3.
So 3 is a prime.
And now I go back through what
I'm left with, and I cross out
all the things divisible by 3.
So let's see, 9 and 15 and 21
and 27 and 33 and so on.
I won't finish.
Then I see what I'm left with.
And the next one I have is 5.
Now I can through the rest,
and I find the first one
that's divisible by 5.
I cross out from the remainder
all the ones that are
divisible by 5.
And I do that, and then I
go through and find 7.
Go through all the rest, cross
out things divisible 7, and I
keep doing that forever.
And when I'm done, what
I'm left with is a
list of all the primes.
So that's the Sieve
of Eratosthenes.
Let's look at it as a
computer program.
It's a procedure called sieve.
Now, I just write what I did.
I'll say to sieve
some stream s.
I'm going to build a stream
whose first element is the
head of this.
Remember, I always found the
first thing I was left with,
and the rest of it is the result
of taking the tail of
this, filtering it to throw away
all the things that are
divisible by the head of this,
and now sieving the result.
That's just what I did.
And now to get the infinite
stream of times, we just sieve
all the integers starting
from 2.
Let's try that.
We can actually do it.
I typed in the definition of
sieve before, I hope, so I can
say something like define the
primes to be the result of
sieving the integers
starting with 2.
So now I've got this
list of primes.
That's all of the
primes, right?
So, if for example, what's the
20th prime in that list?
73.
See, and that little pause, it
was only at the point when I
started asking for
the 20th prime is
that it started computing.
Or I can say here let's look
at all of the primes.
And there it goes computing
all of the primes.
Of course, it will take a while
again if I want to look
at all of them, so
let's stop it.
Let me draw you a
picture of that.
Well, I've got a picture
of that.
What's that program
really look like?
Again, some practice with
these diagrams, I
have a sieve box.
How does sieve work?
It takes in a stream.
It splits off the head
from the tail.
And the first thing that's going
to come out of the sieve
is the head of the
original stream.
Then it also takes the
head and uses that.
It takes the stream.
It filters the tail and uses
the head to filter for
nondivisibility.
It takes the result of
nondivisibility and puts it
through another sieve box and
puts the result together.
So you can think of this sieve a
filter, but notice that it's
an infinitely recursive
filter.
Because inside the sieve box
is another sieve box, and
inside that is another sieve
box and another sieve box.
So you see we start getting
some very powerful things.
We're starting to mix this
signal processing view of the
world with things like recursion
that come from
computation.
And there are all sorts of
interesting things you can do
that are like this.
All right, any questions?
OK, let's take a break.
Well, we've been looking at a
couple of examples of stream
programming.
All the stream procedures that
we've looked at so far have
the same kind of character.
We've been writing these
recursive procedures that kind
of generate these stream
elements one at a time and put
them together in cons-streams.
So we've been thinking a lot
about generators.
There's another way to think
about stream processing, and
that's to focus not on programs
that sort of process
these elements as you walk down
the stream, but on things
that kind of process the
streams all at once.
To show you what I mean, let
me start by defining two
procedures that will
come in handy.
The first one's called add
streams. Add streams takes two
streams: s1 and s2.
and.
It's going to produce a stream
whose elements are the are the
corresponding sums. We just sort
of add them element-wise.
If either stream is empty, we
just return the other one.
Otherwise, we're going to make a
new stream whose head is the
sum of the two heads and whose
tail is the result of
recursively adding the tails.
So that will produce the
element-wise sum of two
streams.
And then another useful
thing to have
around is scale stream.
Scale stream takes some constant
number in a stream s
and is going to produce the
stream of elements of s
multiplied by this constant.
And that's easy, that's just
a map of the function of an
element that multiplies it by
the constant, and we map that
down the stream.
So given those two, let me
show you what I mean by
programs that operate on
streams all at once.
Let's look at this.
Suppose I write this.
I say define--
I'll call it ones--
to be cons-stream
of 1 onto ones.
What's that?
That's going to be an infinite
stream of ones because the
first thing is 1.
And the tail of it is a thing
whose first thing is 1 and
whose tail is a thing whose
first thing is 1 and so on and
so on and so on.
So that's an infinite
stream of ones.
And now using that, let me give
you another definition of
the integers.
We can define the
integers to be--
well, the first integer we'll
take to be 1, this cons-stream
of 1 onto the element-wise sum
onto add streams of the
integers to ones.
The integers are a thing whose
first element is 1, and the
rest of them you get by taking
those integers and
incrementing each one by one.
So the second element of the
integers is the first element
of the integers incremented
by one.
And the rest of that is the
next one, and the third
element of that is the same as
the first element of the tail
of the integers incremented by
one, which is the same as the
first element of the original
integers incremented by one
and incremented by one
again and so on.
That looks pretty suspicious.
See, notice that it works
because of delay.
See, this looks like--
let's take a look at ones.
This looks like it couldn't even
be processed because it's
suddenly saying in order to know
what ones is, I say it's
cons-stream of something
onto ones.
The reason that works is because
of that very sneaky
hidden delay in there.
Because what this really is,
remember, cons-stream is just
an abbreviation.
This really is cons of
1 onto delay of ones.
So how does that work?
You say I'm going
to define ones.
First I see what ones is
supposed to be defined as.
Well, ones is supposed to be
defined as a cons whose first
part is 1 and whose second part
is, well, it's a promise
to compute something that
I don't worry about yet.
So it doesn't bother me that
at the point I do this
definition, ones
isn't defined.
Having run the definition
now, ones is defined.
So that when I go and look at
the tail of it, it's defined.
It's very sneaky.
And an integer is
the same way.
I can refer to integers here
because hidden way down--
because of this cons-stream.
It's the cons-stream of 1
onto something that I
don't worry that yet.
So I don't look at it, and I
don't notice that integers
isn't defined at the point
where I try and run the
definition.
OK, let me draw a picture of
that integers thing because it
still maybe seems a
little bit shaky.
What do I do?
I've got the stream of ones, and
that sort of comes in and
goes into an adder that's
going to be
this add streams thing.
And that goes in--
that's going to put
out the integers.
And the other thing that goes
into the adder here is the
integer, so there's a little
feedback loop.
And all I need to start it off
is someplace I've got a stick
that initial 1.
In a real signal processing
thing, this might be a delay
element with that was
initialized to 1.
But there's a picture of
that ones program.
And in fact, that looks
a lot like--
if you've seen real signal block
diagram things, that
looks a lot like accumulators,
finite state accumulators.
And in fact, we can modify this
a little bit to change
this into something that
integrates a stream or a
finite state accumulator,
however you like
to think about it.
So instead of the ones coming
in and getting out the
integers, what we'll do is say
there's a stream s coming in,
and we're going to get out the
integral of this, successive
values of that, and it looks
almost the same.
The only thing we're going to
do is when s comes in here,
before we just add it in we're
going to multiply it
by some number dt.
And now what we have
here, this is
exactly the same thing.
We have a box, which
is an integrator.
And it takes in a stream s, and
instead of 1 here, we can
put the additional value
for the integral.
And that one looks very much
like a signal processing block
diagram program.
In fact, here's the procedure
that looks exactly like that.
Find the integral of a stream.
So an integral's going to take
a stream and produce a new
stream, and it takes
in an initial value
and some time constant.
And what do we do?
Well, we internally define this
thing int, and we make
this internal name so
we can feed it back,
loop it around itself.
And int is defined to be
something that starts out at
the initial value, and
the rest of it is
gotten by adding together.
We take our input stream,
scale it by dt,
and add that to int.
And now we'll return from all
that the value of integral is
this thing int.
And we use this internal
definition syntax so we could
write a little internal
definition
that refers to itself.
Well, there are all sorts
of things we can do.
Let's try this one.
how about the Fibonacci
numbers.
You can say define fibs.
Well, what are the Fibonacci
numbers?
They're something that starts
out with 0, and
the next one is 1.
And the rest of the Fibonacci
numbers are gotten by adding
the Fibonacci numbers
to their own tail.
There's a definition of
the Fibonacci numbers.
How does that work?
Well, we start off, and someone
says compute for us
the Fibonacci numbers, and we're
going to tell you it
starts out with 0 and 1.
And everything after the 0 and
1 is gotten by summing two
streams. One is the fibs
themselves, and the other one
is the tail of the fibs.
So if I know that these start
out with 0 and 1, I know that
the fibs now start out with 0
and 1, and the tail of the
fibs start out with 1.
So as soon as I know that, I
know that the next one here is
0 plus 1 is 1, and that tells me
that the next one here is 1
and the next one here is 1.
And as soon as I know that, I
know that the next one is 2.
So the next one here is 2 and
the next one here is 2.
And this is 3.
This one goes to 3,
and this is 5.
So it's a perfectly sensible
definition.
It's a one-line definition.
And again, I could walk over to
the computer and type that
in, exactly that, and then say
print stream the Fibonacci
numbers, and they all
come flying out.
See, this is a lot
like learning
about recursion again.
Instead of thinking that
recursive procedures, we have
recursively defined
data objects.
But that shouldn't surprise you
at all, because by now,
you should be coming to really
believe that there's no
difference really between
procedures and data.
In fact, in some sense, the
underlying streams are
procedures sitting there,
although we don't think of
them that way.
So the fact that we have
recursive procedures, well,
then it should be natural that
we have recursive data, too.
OK, well, this is
all pretty neat.
Unfortunately, there are
problems that streams aren't
going to solve.
Let me show you one of them.
See, in the same way, let's
imagine that we're building an
analog computer to solve some
differential equation like,
say, we want to solve the
equation y prime dy dt is y
squared, and I'm going to give
you some initial value.
I'll tell you y of 0 equals 1.
Let's say dt is equal
to something.
Now, in the old days, people
built analog computers to
solve these kinds of things.
And the way you do that
is really simple.
You get yourself an integrator,
like that one, an
integrator box.
And we put in the initial
value y of 0 is 1.
And now if we feed something
in and get something out,
we'll say, gee, what we're
getting out is the answer.
And what we're going to feed in
is the derivative, and the
derivative is supposed to be
the square of the answer.
So if we take these values and
map using square, and if I
feed this around, that's how I
build a block diagram for an
analog computer that solves this
differential equation.
Now, what we'd like to do is
write a stream program that
looks exactly like that.
And what do I mean exactly
like that?
Well, I'd say define y to be the
integral of dy starting at
1 with 0.001 as a time step.
And I'd like to say
that says this.
And then I'd like to say, well,
dy is gotten by mapping
the square along y.
So define dy to be map
square along y.
So there's a stream description
of this analog
computer, and unfortunately,
it doesn't work.
And you can see why it doesn't
work because when I come in
and say define y to be the
integral of dy, it says, oh,
the integral of y-- huh?
Oh, that's undefined.
So I can't write this definition
before I've
written this one.
On the other hand, if I try and
write this one first, it
says, oh, I define y to be the
map of square along y?
Oh, that's not defined yet.
So I can't write this one first,
and I can't write that
one first. So I can't quite
play this game.
Well, is there a way out?
See, we can do that with ones.
See, over here, we did this
thing ones, and we were able
to define ones in terms of ones
because of this delay
that was built inside because
cons-stream had a delay.
Now, why's it sensible?
Why's it sensible for
cons-stream to be built with
this delay?
The reason is that cons-stream
can do a useful thing without
looking at its tail.
See, if I say this is
cons-stream of 1 onto
something without knowing
anything about something, I
know that the stream
starts off with 1.
That's why it was sensible
to build something like
cons-stream.
So we put a delay in there,
and that allows us to have
this sort of self-referential
definition.
Well, integral is a little
bit the same way.
See, notice for an
integral, I can--
let's go back and look at
integral for a second.
See, notice integral, it makes
sense to say what's the first
thing in the integral without
knowing the stream that you're
integrating.
Because the first thing in the
integral is always going to be
the initial value that
you're handed.
So integral could be a procedure
like cons-stream.
You could define it, and then
even before it knows what it's
supposed to be integrating, it
knows enough to say what its
initial value is.
So we can make a smarter
integral, which is aha, you're
going to give me a stream to
integrate and an initial
value, but I really don't have
to look at that stream that
I'm supposed to integrate until
you ask me to work down
the stream.
In other words, integral can be
like cons-stream, and you
can expect that there's
going to be a
delay around its integrand.
And we can write that.
Here's a procedure
that does that.
Another version of integral,
and this is almost like the
previous one, except the stream
it's going to get in is
going to expect to be
a delayed object.
And how does this
integral work?
Well, the little thing it's
going to define inside of
itself says on the cons-stream,
the initial value
is the initial value, but only
inside of that cons-stream,
and remember, there's going to
be a hidden delay inside here.
Only inside of that cons-stream
will I start
looking at what the actual
delayed object is.
So my answer is the first
thing's the initial value.
If anybody now asks me for my
tail, at that point, I'm going
to force that delayed object--
and I'll call that s--
and I do the add streams. So
this is an integral which is
sort of like cons-stream.
It's not going to actually try
and see what you handed it as
the thing to integrate
until you look
past the first element.
And if we do that and we can
make this work, all we have to
do here is say define y to the
integral of delay of y, of
delay of dy.
So y is going to be the integral
of delay of dy
starting at 1, and now
this will work.
Because I type in the definition
of y, and that
says, oh, I'm supposed to use
the integral of something I
don't care about right now
because it's a delay.
And these things, now
you define dy.
Now, y is defined.
So when I define dy, it can
see that definition for y.
Everything is now started up.
Both streams have their
first element.
And then when I start mapping
down, looking at successive
elements, both y and
dy are defined.
So there's a little game you
can play that goes a little
bit beyond just using the delay
that's hidden inside
streams. Questions?
OK, let's take a break.
Well, just before the break,
I'm not sure if you noticed
it, but something nasty
started to happen.
We've been going along with the
streams and divorcing time
in the programs from time in
the computers, and all that
divorcing got hidden inside the
streams. And then at the
very end, we saw that sometimes
in order to really
take advantage of this
method, you have to
pull out other delays.
You have to write some explicit
delays that are not
hidden inside that
cons-stream.
And I did a very simple example
with differential
equations, but if you have some
very complicated system
with all kinds of self-loops,
it becomes very, very
difficult to see where you
need those delays.
And if you leave them out by
mistake, it becomes very, very
difficult to see why the thing
maybe isn't working.
So that's kind of mess, that
by getting this power and
allowing us to use delay,
we end up with some very
complicated programming
sometimes, because it can't
all be hidden inside
the streams.
Well, is there a way
out of that?
Yeah, there is a way
out of that.
We could change the language so
that all procedures acted
like cons-stream, so that every
procedure automatically
has an implicit delay around
its arguments.
And what would that mean?
That would mean when you call
a procedure, the arguments
wouldn't get evaluated.
Instead, they'd only be
evaluated when you need them,
so they might be passed off to
some other procedure, which
wouldn't evaluate them either.
So all these procedures would
be passing promises around.
And then finally maybe when you
finally got down to having
to look at the value of
something that was handed to a
primitive operator would you
actually start calling in all
those promises.
If we did that, since everything
would have a
uniform delay, then you wouldn't
have to write any
explicit delays, because it
would be automatically built
into the way the
language works.
Or another way to say that,
technically what I'm
describing is what's called--
if we did that, our language
would be so-called
normal-order evaluation language
versus what we've
actually been working
with, which is
called applicative order--
versus applicative-order
evaluation.
And remember the substitution
model for applicative order.
It says when you go and evaluate
a combination, you
find the values of
all the pieces.
You evaluate the arguments and
then you substitute them in
the body of the procedure.
Normal order says no,
don't do that.
What you do is effectively
substitute in the body of the
procedure, but instead of
evaluating the arguments, you
just put a promise to
compute them there.
Or another way to say that is
you take the expressions for
the arguments, if you like,
and substitute them in the
body of the procedure and go on,
and never really simplify
anything until you get down
to a primitive operator.
So that would be a normal-order
language.
Well, why don't we do that?
Because if we did, we'd get all
the advantages of delayed
evaluation with none
of the mess.
In fact, if we did that and
cons was just a delayed
procedure, that would make cons
the same as cons-stream.
We wouldn't need streams of
all because lists would
automatically be streams. That's
how lists would behave,
and data structures would
behave that way.
Everything would behave
that way, right?
You'd never really do any
computation until you actually
needed the answer.
You wouldn't have to worry
about all these explicit
annoying delays.
Well, why don't we do that?
First of all, I should say
people do do that.
There's some very beautiful
languages.
One of the very nicest is a
language called Miranda, which
is developed by David Turner
at the University of Kent.
And that's how this
language works.
It's a normal-order language and
its data structures, which
look like lists, are actually
streams. And you write
ordinary procedures in Miranda,
and they do these
prime things and eight
queens things, just
without anything special.
It's all built in there.
But there's a price.
Remember how we got here.
We're decoupling time
in the programs
from time in the machines.
And if we put delay, that sort
of decouples it everywhere,
not just in streams. Remember
what we're trying to do.
We're trying to think about
programming as a way to
specify processes.
And if we give up too much time,
our language becomes
more elegant, but it becomes a
little bit less expressive.
There are certain distinctions
that we can't draw.
One of them, for instance,
is iteration.
Remember this old procedure,
iterative factorial, that we
looked at quite a
long time ago.
Iterative factorial had a thing,
and it said there was
an internal procedure, and there
was a state which was a
product and a counter,
and we iterate that
going around the loop.
And we said that was an
iterative procedure because it
didn't build up state.
And the reason it didn't build
up state is because this iter
that's called is just passing
these things around to itself.
Or in the substitution model,
you could see in the
substitution model that Jerry
did, that in an iterative
procedure, that state doesn't
have to grow.
And in fact, we said
it doesn't,
so this is an iteration.
But now think about this exact
same text if we had a
normal-order language.
What would happen is this
would no longer be an
iterative procedure?
And if you really think about
the details of the
substitution model, which I'm
not going to do here, this
expression would grow.
Why would it grow?
It's because when iter calls
itself, it calls itself with
this product.
If it's a normal-order language,
that multiplication
is not going to get done.
That's going to say I'm to call
myself with a promise to
compute this product.
And now iter goes
around again.
And I'm going to call myself
with a promise to compute this
product where now one of the
one factors is a promise.
And I call myself again.
And if you write out the
substitution model for that
iterative process, you'll see
exactly the same growth in
state, all those promises that
are getting remembered that
have to get called in
at the very end.
So one of the disadvantages
is that you can't
really express iteration.
Maybe that's a little
theoretical reason why not,
but in fact, people who are
trying to write real operating
systems in these languages are
running into exactly these
types of problems. Like it's
perfectly possible to
implement a text editor in
languages like these.
But after you work a while, you
suddenly have 3 megabytes
of stuff, which is--
I guess they call them the
dragging tail problem of
people who are looking at these,
of promises that sort
of haven't been called in
because you couldn't quite
express an iteration.
And one of the research
questions in these kinds of
languages are figuring out the
right compiler technology to
get rid of the so-called
dragging tails.
It's not simple.
But there's another kind of more
striking issue about why
you just don't go ahead
and make your
language normal order.
And the reason is that
normal-order evaluation and
side effects just don't mix.
They just don't go together
very well.
Somehow, you can't--
it's sort of you can't
simultaneously go around
trying to model objects with
local state and change and at
the same time do these
normal-order tricks of
de-coupling time.
Let me just show you
a really simple
example, very, very simple.
Suppose we had a normal-order
language.
And I'm going to start
out in this language.
This is now normal order.
I'm going to define x to be 0.
It's just some variable
I'll initialize.
And now I'm going to define this
little funny function,
which is an identity function.
And what it does, it keeps track
of the last time you
called it using x.
So the identity of n just
returns n, but it
sets x to be n.
And now I'll define a little
increment function, which is a
very little, simple scenario.
Now, imagine I'm interacting
with this in the normal-order
language, and I type
the following.
I say define y to be increment
the identity function of 3, so
y is going to be 4.
Now, I say what's x?
Well, x should have been the
value that was remembered last
when I called the identity
function.
So you'd expect to say,
well, x is 3 at this
point, but it's not.
Because when I defined y here,
what I really defined y to be
increment of a promise
to do this thing.
So I didn't look at y,
so that identity
function didn't get run.
So if I type in this definition
and look at x, I'm
going to get 0.
Now, if I go look at y and say
what's y, say y is 4, looking
at y, that very active looking
at y caused the identity
function to be run.
And now x will get
remembered as 3.
So here x will be 0.
Here, x will be 3.
That's a tiny, little, simple
scenario, but you can see what
kind of a mess that's going to
make for debugging interactive
programs when you have
normal-order evaluation.
It's very confusing.
But it's very confusing for a
very deep reason, which is
that the whole idea of putting
in delays is that
you throw away time.
That's why we can have these
infinite processes.
Since we've thrown away time, we
don't have to wait for them
to run, right?
We decouple the order of events
in the computer from
what we write in our programs.
But when we talk about state
and set and change, that's
exactly what we do want
control of.
So it's almost as if there's
this fundamental contradiction
in what you want.
And that brings us back to these
sort of philosophical
mutterings about what is it that
you're trying to model
and how do you look
at the world.
Or sometimes this is called
the debate over functional
programming.
A so-called purely functional
language is one that just
doesn't have any side effects.
Since you have no side effects,
there's no assignment
operator, so there are no
terrible consequences of it.
You can use a substitution-like
thing.
Programs really are like
mathematics and not like
models in the real
world, not like
objects in the real world.
There are a lot of
wonderful things
about functional languages.
Since there's no time, you never
have any synchronization
problems. And if you want to put
something into a parallel
algorithm, you can run the
pieces of that parallel
processing any way you want.
There's just never any
synchronization to worry that,
and it's a very congenial
environment for doing this.
The price is you give
up assignment.
So an advocate of a functional
language would say, gee,
that's just a tiny
price to pay.
You probably shouldn't
use assignment
most of the time anyway.
And if you just give up
assignment, you can be in this
much, much nicer world than
this place with objects.
Well, what's the rejoinder
to that?
Remember how we got
into this mess.
We started trying to model
things that had local state.
So remember Jerry's random
number generator.
There was this random number
generator that had some little
state in it to compute the next
random number and the
next random number and the
next random number.
And we wanted to hide that state
away from the Cesaro
compute part process, and that's
why we needed set.
We wanted to package that
stated modularly.
Well, a functional programming
person would say, well, you're
just all wet.
I mean, you can write
a perfectly
good modular program.
It's just you're thinking
about modularity wrong.
You're hung up in this next
random number and the next
random number and the
next random number.
Why don't you just say let's
write a program.
Let's write an enumerator
which just generates an
infinite stream of
random numbers.
We can sort of have that stream
all at once, and that's
going to be our source
of random numbers.
And then if you like, you can
put that through some sort of
processor, which is--
I don't know--
a Cesaro test, and that
can do what it wants.
And what would come out of there
would be a stream of
successive approximations
to pi.
So as we looked further down
this stream, we'd tug on this
Cesaro thing, and it
would pull out more
and more random numbers.
And the further and further we
look down the stream, the
better an approximation
we'd get to pi.
And it would do exactly the same
as the other computation,
except we're thinking about
the modularity different.
We're saying imagine we had all
those infinite streams of
random numbers all at once.
You can see the details of this
procedure in the book.
Similarly, there are other
things that we tend to get
locked into on this one and that
one and the next one and
the next one, which don't
have to be that way.
Like you might think about like
a banking system, which
is a very simple idea.
Imagine we have a program
that sort of
represents a bank account.
The bank account might
have in it--
if we looked at this in a sort
of message-passing view of the
world, we'd say a bank account
is an object that has some
local state in there, which
is the balance, say.
And a user using this system
comes and sends a transaction
request. So the user sends a
transaction request, like
deposit some money, and the
bank account maybe--
let's say the bank account
always responds with what the
current balance is.
The user says let's deposits
some money, and the bank
account sends back a message
which is the balance.
And the user says deposit some
more, and the bank account
sends back a message.
And just like the random number
generator, you'd say,
gee, we would like to use set.
We'd like to have balance be a
piece of local state inside
this bank account because we
want to separate the state of
the user from the state
of the bank account.
Well, that's the
message-processing view.
There's a stream view with that
thing, which does the
same thing without any
set or side effects.
And the idea is again we don't
think about anything having
local state.
We think about the bank account
as something that's
going to process a stream
of transaction requests.
So think about this bank account
not as something that
goes message by message, but
something that takes in a
stream of transaction
requests like maybe
successive deposit announced.
1, 2, 2, 4, those might be
successive amounts to deposit.
And then coming out of
it is the successive
balances 1, 3, 5, 9.
So we think of the bank account
not as something that
has state, but something that
acts sort of on the infinite
stream of requests.
But remember, we've
thrown away time.
So what we can do is if the
user's here, we can have this
infinite stream of requests
being generated one at a time
coming from the user and this
transaction stream coming back
on a printer being printed
one at a time.
And if we drew a little line
here, right there to the user,
the user couldn't tell
that this system
doesn't have state.
It looks just like the
other one, but
there's no state in there.
And by the way, just to show
you, here's an actual
implementation of this-- we'll
call it make deposit account
because you can only deposit.
It takes an initial balance and
then a stream of deposits
you might make.
And what is it?
Well, it's just cons-stream of
the balance onto make a new
account stream whose initial
balance is the old balance
plus the first thing in the
deposit stream and make
deposit account works on the
rest of which is the tail of
the deposit stream.
So there's sort of a very
typical message-passing,
object-oriented thing
that's done without
side effects at all.
There are very many things
you can do this way.
Well, can you do everything
without assignment?
Can everybody go over to purely
functional languages?
Well, we don't know, but there
seem to be places where purely
functional programming
breaks down.
Where it starts hurting is
when you have things like
this, but you also mix it up
with the other things that we
had to worry that, which are
objects and sharing and two
independent agents
being the same.
So under a typical one, suppose
you want to extend
this bank account.
So here's a bank account.
Bank accounts take in a stream
of transaction requests and
put out streams of, say,
balances or responses to that.
But suppose you want to model
the fact that this is a joint
bank account between two
independent people.
So suppose there are two people,
say, Bill and Dave,
who have a joint bank account.
How would you model this?
Well, Bill puts out a stream of
transaction requests, and
Dave puts out a stream of
somehow, they have to merge
into this bank account.
So what you might do is write
a little stream processing
thing called merge, which sort
of takes these, merges them
together, produces a single
stream for the bank account.
Now they're both talking to
the same bank account.
That's all great, but how
do you write merge?
What's this procedure merge?
You want to do something
that's reasonable.
Your first guess might be
to say, well, we'll take
alternate requests from Bill and
Dave. But what happens if
suddenly in the middle of this
thing, Dave goes away on
vacation for two years?
Then Bill's sort of stuck.
So what you want to do is--
well, it's hard to describe.
What you want to do is what
people call fair merge.
The idea of fair merge is it
sort of should do them
alternately, but if there's
nothing waiting here, it
should take one twice.
Notice I can't even say that
without talking about time.
So one of the other active
researcher areas in functional
languages is inventing little
things like fair merge and
maybe some others, which will
take the places where I used
to need side effects and objects
and sort of hide them
away in some very well-defined
modules of the system so that
all the problems of assignment
don't sort of leak out all
over the system but are captured
in some fairly
well-understood things.
More generally, I think what
you're seeing is that we're
running across what I think
is a very basic problem in
computer science, which is how
to define languages that
somehow can talk about delayed
evaluation, but also be able
to reflect this view
that there are
objects in the world.
How do we somehow get both?
And I think that's a
very hard problem.
And it may be that it's a very
hard problem that has almost
nothing to do with computer
science, that it really is a
problem having to do with two
very incompatible ways of
looking at the world.
OK, questions?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
earlier that once you
introduce assignment, the
general rule for using the
substitution model
is you can't.
Unless you're very careful,
you can't.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is there a set of
techniques or a set of
guidelines for localizing the
effects of assignment so that
the very careful becomes
defined?
PROFESSOR: I don't know.
Let me think.
Well, certainly, there was an
assignment inside memo proc,
but that was sort
of hidden away.
It ended up not making
any difference.
Part of the reason for that is
once this thing triggered that
it had run and gotten
an answer, that
answer will never change.
So that was sort of a
one-time assignment.
So one very general thing you
can do is if you only do
what's called a one-time
assignment and never change
anything, then you
can do better.
One of the problems in this
merge thing, people have--
let me see if this is right.
I think it's true that with
fair merge, with just fair
merge, you can begin effectively
simulating
assignment in the rest
of the language.
It seems like anything you
do to go outside--
I'm not quite sure that's true
for fair merge, but it's true
of a little bit more
general things that
people have been doing.
So it might be that any little
bit you put in, suddenly if
they allow you to build
arbitrary stuff, it's almost
as bad as having assignment
altogether.
But that's an area that people
are thinking about now.
AUDIENCE: I guess I don't see
the problem here with merge if
I call Bill, if Bill is a
procedure, then Bill is going
to increment the bank account
or build the list that 's
going to put in the
next element.
If I call Dave twice in a
row, that will do that.
I'm not sure where fair merge
has to be involved.
PROFESSOR: The problem
is imagine
these really as people.
See, here I have the user who's
interacting with this
bank account.
Put in a request,
get an answer.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: But if the only way
I can process request is to
alternate them from
two people--
AUDIENCE: Well, why would
you alternate them?
PROFESSOR: Why don't I?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Why do you?
PROFESSOR: Think of them
as real people, right?
This guy might go
away for a year.
And you're sitting here at the
bank account window, and you
can't put in two requests
because it's
waiting for this guy.
AUDIENCE: Why does it have
to be waiting for one?
PROFESSOR: Because it's trying
to compute a function.
I have to define a function.
Another way to say that is the
answer to what comes out of
this merge box is not a function
of what goes in.
Because, see, what would
the function be?
Suppose he puts in 1, 1, 1, 1,
and he puts in 2, 2, 2, 2.
What's the answer
supposed to be?
It's not good enough to say
it's 1, 2, 1, 2, 1, 2.
AUDIENCE: I understand.
But when Bill puts
in 1, 1 goes in.
When Dave puts in 2 twice,
2 goes in twice.
When Bill puts in--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Why can't
it be hooked to
the time of the input--
the actual procedural--
PROFESSOR: Because I
don't have time.
See, all I can say is I'm going
to define a function.
I don't have time.
There's no concept if it's going
to alternate, except if
nobody's there, it's going
to wait a while for him.
It's just going to say I have
the stream of requests, the
timeless infinite streams of
all the requests that Dave
would have made, right?
And the timeless infinite stream
of all the requests
Bill would have made, and I
want to operate on them.
See, that's how this bank
account is working.
And the problem is that these
poor people who are sitting at
the bank account windows
have the
misfortune to exist in time.
They don't see their infinite
stream of all the requests
they would have ever made.
They're waiting now, and
they want an answer.
So if you're sitting there--
if this is the screen operation
on some time-sharing
system and it's working
functionally, you want an
answer then when you
talk the character.
You don't want it to have to
wait for everybody in the
whole system to have typed one
character before it can get
around to service you.
So that's the problem.
I mean, the fact that people
live in time, apparently.
If they didn't, it wouldn't
be a problem.
AUDIENCE: I'm afraid I miss the
point of having no time in
this banking transaction.
Isn't time very important?
For instance, the sequence
of events.
If Dave take out $100,
then the timing
sequence should be important.
How do you treat transactions
as streams?
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
the thing I'm saying.
This is an example
where you can't.
You can't.
The point is what comes out of
here is simply not a function
of the stream going in here and
the stream going in here.
It's a function of the stream
going in here and the stream
going in here and some kind of
information about time, which
is precisely what a normal-order
language won't
let you say.
AUDIENCE: In order to brings
this back into a more
functional perspective, could we
just explicitly time stamp
all the inputs from Bill and
Dave and define fair merge to
just be the sort on
those time stamps?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you
can do that.
You can do that sort of thing.
Another thing you could say is
imagine that really what this
function is, is that it does a
read every microsecond, and
then if there's none
there, that's
considered an empty one.
That's about equivalent
to what you said.
And yes, you can do that,
but that's a clg.
So it's not quite only
implementation
we're worried about.
We're worried about expressive
power in the language, and
what we're running across is a
real mismatch between what we
can say easily and what
we'd like to say.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like where
we're getting hung up with
that is the fact it expects one
input from both Bill and
Dave at the same time.
PROFESSOR: It's not quite one,
but it's anything you define.
So you can say Dave can go
twice as often, but if
anything you predefine, it's
not the right thing.
You can't decide at some
particular function of their
input requests.
Worse yet, I mean, worse yet,
there are things that even
merge can't do.
One thing you might want to do
that's even more general is
suddenly you add somebody else
to this bank account system.
You go and you add John to
this bank account system.
And now there's yet another
stream that's going to come
into the picture at some time
which we haven't prespecified.
So that's something even fair
merge can't do, and they're
things called--
I forget--
natagers or something.
That's a generalization of
fair merge to allow that.
There's a whole sort of research
discipline saying how
far can you push this functional
perspective by
adding more and more
mechanism?
And how far does that go before
the whole thing breaks
down and you might as well
been using set anyway.
AUDIENCE: You need to set him
up on automatic deposit.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK, thank you.